es wird immer klarer wir haben ein
gigantisches plastikmüll probleme auf
unserer erde
plastik ist mittlerweile überall in
unseren körpern am straßenrand in der
luft wie ich letztens berichtet habe in
den wäldern und in den tiefen des ozeans
doch es gibt viele kreative ideen um
gegen die risiken plastik berger
anzugehen oder sie zukünftig sogar ganz
zu vermeiden
hier die vier besten lösungsideen um
unsere erde vielleicht doch noch von dem
gigantischen umwelt killer plastik zu
erlösen herzlich willkommen bei klick
zum science fiction und danke für den
themenvorschlag bei %
alleine in den meeren schwimmen
schätzungen zufolge mehr als fünf
millionen plastikteile
das ist eine zahl mit 18 nullen
unvorstellbar und auf unseren tellern
landet der plastikmüll täglich aus der
luft in jeder mahlzeit die wir zu uns
nehmen sind rund 100 mikro
plastikteilchen ein forschungsteam von
der harry atwater university in
edinburgh untersucht den wieviel micro
plastikteilchen während einer mahlzeit
aus der luft auf dem teller landen
es waren 100 und damit sind 70.000 im
jahr die wir essen es ist wirklich ein
riesenproblem
aber wie kann es gelöst werden erste
idee walking joggen und sammeln diese
idee ist vor allem für diejenigen unter
euch gedacht die sowieso gerne sport
machen und sich dabei vielleicht sogar
noch vorstellen können auch der umwelt
etwas gutes zu tun
blogging setzt sich zusammen aus dem
wort doping und dem schwedischen begriff
blog also sammeln die idee joggen gehen
und dabei müll aufheben sammeln und am
ende entsorgt tatsächlich in schweden
eine trendsportart die es mittlerweile
auch in immer mehr deutschen städten
gibt und was soll ich sagen wenn ihr
euch blickt in die knie geht und euch
dann nach dem einsammeln des mülls
wieder aufrichtet trainiert er damit
noch mehr muskeln als beim einfachen
laufen aber achtung nicht zu schnell
machen
dann fällt man nämlich automatisch um
macht das haben wir immer in der
grundschule gemacht ist auf jeden fall
lust sich aber auch gefährlich kann man
sich böse verletzen zurück zum thema
zweite idee die weltmeere vom plastik
befreien die bilder sind mehr als
erschreckend in den ozean tragen
gigantische müllteppich um die meere
davon zu befreien gibt es viele einzelne
gute ideen und aktionen denn fest steht
mit fang teppichen wird es ewig dauert
deswegen wurde jetzt beispielsweise eine
bis zu zwei kilometer lange
schlauchförmige boje entwickelt die den
müll einsammelt das tolle daran sie
treibt völlig autonom mehr und schiffe
holen den von ihr gesammelten müll ab
lebewesen werden nicht gefährdet denn
die werden unter die barrieren gedrückt
die elektrischen komponenten werden von
solarenergie betrieben und somit ist die
erfindung komplett klimaneutral ab 2020
sollen sie in allen weltmeeren
eingesetzt werden bis dahin läuft noch
das crowdfunding von
roshan cleanup zudem gibt es einen
finanziellen zuschuss der
niederländischen regierung eine weitere
idee in diesem zusammenhang ist das
sogenannte screening das modell erinnert
an einem überdimensionalen rochen der
409 und 400 meter misst und an drei
seiten geschlossen ist die idee stammt
von einer architektin aus aachen die
damit auch schon einige preise gewonnen
hat die konstruktion soll durch
drahtseile am meeresboden befestigt
werden so dass die offene seite zur
strömung zeit durch den austausch von
tiefen und oberflächenwasser wird
plastik tatsächlich bis in eine tiefe
von 30 metern befördert plastik und
plastik partikel werden so gefiltert und
können recycelt werden und in
computermodellen hat diese technik
tatsächlich schon gut funktioniert im
raum steht jetzt noch die frage der
finanzierung dritte idee plastik
fressende bakterien schon vor zwei
jahren machte ein forschungsteam aus
japan eine aufregende entdeckung in der
nähe einer recycling fabrik für
pet-flaschen entdeckten sie bakterien
die sich hauptsächlich vom plastik
ernährten sie nannten sie in eller sagt
karin s 201 strich 11 6 und ließen sie
unter laborbedingungen einen feinen
plastik film fressen
dafür brauchten die bakterien 60 wochen
also leider viel zu lange um gegen den
müll im meer an zu kämpfen doch auch
britische und amerikanische
forschungsteams hatten derweil mikroben
entdeckt die sogar auf dem plastikmüll
im ozean siedeln und den kunststoff
auffressen
wie genau das passiert und ob sie dabei
gegebenenfalls giftstoffe freisetzen ist
allerdings noch nicht bekannt doch
trotzdem gibt es die idee müll fressende
mikroben auf das plastik im meer auf dem
plastikmeer auszusetzen
doch das ist mehr als umstritten denn
schließlich sind die folgen auf das
ökosystem
je mehr völlig unklar vierte idee
sinnvolle alternative bioplastik aus
organischem abfall ja endlich mal das
problem bei der wurzel packen
über diese idee hatten wir hier bei
klick zum science und fiction berichtet
und sagt geht es um einen wirklich eine
sinnvolle alternative zu den
umweltschädlichen plastik bioplastik
nämlich je gestellt aus organischem
abfall also beispielsweise essensresten
müll
aus dem landwirtschaftlichen bereich
oder auch kartons die dann kompostiert
werden mit dieser idee will das
unternehmen fuß bioplastics dem
gigantischen plastik problem unserer
erde den kampf ansagen und gleichzeitig
vielleicht auch unser leben
revolutionären in einer eigens von ihnen
entwickelten kompostieranlage laufen
chemische prozesse ab und am ende gibt
es dann ein abwasser dass sehr viele
fettsäuren enthält durch den einsatz von
backen werden genau diese fettsäuren in
poley hydroxyl fettsäuren so genanntes
micro verwandelt das ist eine zähe und
milchige masse die man dann zur
verpackung pressen kann
das tolle an diesem konzept anders als
andere hersteller werden hierbei keine
extra chemikalien oder extra gezüchtete
pflanzen benötigt und wenn die
produzierten produkte nicht mehr
gebraucht werden nimmt die firma sie
zurück um wiederum neues bio plastik
daraus herzustellen doch selbst wenn es
in der landschaft oder im wasser landet
ist es dort noch lange nicht so
gefährlich und schädlich wie das
konventionell hergestellte plastik denn
nach angaben der anderson brüder
verrottet ist einfach auf natürliche art
und weise vergleichbar mit laub zudem
sei ihr verfahren co2 neutral brauche
wenig energie und wasser kohlendioxid
wird bei ihrem kompost ihr system
zunächst sogar gebunden wenn die
produkte dann später kompostiert werden
wird es allerdings wieder freigesetzt
aber nicht nur in den usa sondern auch
in deutschland wird an ähnlichen konzept
getüftelt cool würde ich mal sagen und
jetzt gibt es zehn euro für jeden
ungelogen meine whatsapp community hat
mich gebeten einen special deal
auszuhandeln
und ich habe ihm bekommen bei dem vom
stiftung warentest am besten getesteten
cashback portal gibt es zehn euro plus
noch ein sonder cashback das ganze
bekommt der am sonntag wenn ihr euch
hier bei whatsapp anmeldet einfach
draufklicken übervater zudem vom meer
noch vor einem anderen vom neuesten
video täglich garantiert um am besten
auch meinen schwesterkanal klicks social
media abonnieren da gibt es das neueste
aus der social media welt dafür hier
klicken aber nicht die glocke vergessen
hier geht es war damit dafür auch
draufklicken erschreckend wir essen
unmengen micro plastik bis dann bleibt
dran